era conocido como Da Vinci y se había
convertido en un héroe de Ucrania uno de
sus soldados más importantes de allí que
su fallecimiento en esta semana en la
batalla de bacmut allá impactado tanto a
los ucranianos
era una persona fenomenal no pasó ni un
solo día en la academia militar y no
tenía educación militar pero hace seis
meses recibió el título de suboficial
y era comandante de un Batallón esto no
tiene precedentes es un fenómeno
lo conocí en el 2014 y como el resto de
los jóvenes soñaba con vivir en el mundo
libre donde todo el mundo puede viajar o
estudiar libremente en los últimos días
las redes sociales han estado llenas de
fotos de hombres y mujeres que han
muerto en esa batalla por backmud
incluso muchos se han llegado a
preguntar si vale la pena perder tantos
hombres en una batalla que para muchos
no es tan estratégica pero también los
soldados en el terreno nos están adentro
y que nos cuentan Desde allí dicen que
prefieren pelearla actualmente antes de
tener que volver a pelear en el futuro
donde Habrá más pérdidas humanas sin
embargo líder religioso que presidía
esta ceremonia asegurado que Ucrania ha
perdido los mejores hombres con esta
guerra
usted puede ver cuántos hombres jóvenes
y fuertes hay aquí Él les dio el sentido
de que pueden destruir efectivamente al
enemigo seguir vivos y volver a casa eso
es algo muy único que es lo que nos da
el sentimiento de confianza la
importancia de estar aquí es porque Da
Vinci hace parte de esos jóvenes
ucranianos que se unieron por la defensa
de los valores democráticos de su país
en esa Revolución en el 2014 él se unió
como voluntario y más tarde también como
voluntario al ejército pelearon durante
años en el hacía parte de un grupo
conocido como el private sector que
durante esta guerra ya se unido a parte
del ejército hacen parte de las división
número 67 Pero él mismo tenía su propia
unidad llamada Los Lobos de Da Vinci por
eso es importante para todas estas
personas regresar aquí
corazón de kiev a recordar Quién ha sido
uno de sus mayores símbolos